[Music]
hey guys so today we're going to try
something completely new we're going to
do our very first challenge today what
kind of trans are we doing today the
blindfold scary love cheering so we have
to test our knowledge of cereal see if
we can get them all right so you've been
telling you've been wanting the few
challenges right mmm how come because I
say I have seen in JK party I just want
to try something new
yeah you can I can't wait to get started
so first what we're going to be doing
case is going to be bringing out the
bowls of cereal and we have to guess
what flavor that it you know a lot of
cereal and right even though you haven't
read them all okay most all right let's
get started so now let's put on the
blink oh yeah
I can't see anything all right I can see
a little bit in the bottom where I don't
want to do that yeah let's not do that
just closure I don't even keep your eyes
open let's be honest here we're ready
for the first Bowl
so yes let's bring it up
[Music]
all right serial number one inch so
thank you guys all right you ready
first of all here - okay you go for it
take your first simple does that taste
like sauce it's like really lasses know
what kind of flavors
it tastes like cinnamon yeah I think
it's in this imminent Coast or the
moment and let me say when you're in
pretty obvious oh yeah this is my
favorite in this house there's a little
one yeah it's so amazing unless cinnamon
toast crunch
mmm and it just helps no good so go
right so we both agree it's cinnamon
toast crunch ooh so let's not get too
full cuz we got a lot much to feel - I
feel baby
why if X's we're cool reality virtual
reality but your eyes your clothes
branches all right I think we got number
one down right let's see what's number
two it
[Music]
all right serial number two you ready
where is it yes I hope you think you got
it go for it
let me know what you think is that you
click it's pretty odd is you really
it's another obvious one acre lucky turn
really oh man oh I hope the marshmallows
in my time but it doesn't late he have
one look yes I have one think it was
like not a real order oh maybe we use is
in the one okay oh yeah for sure lucky
charm huh yeah the marshmallows are too
sugary for me a little you know logical
say that I'm really weird because I take
out the marshmallow that I might look at
times today I like the cereal I just
don't like the actual marshmallow I love
I love in there you think I'm worried
doing that you all right hurry glad
lucky tie mm all right don't get to
falsity arrow number three mm-hm
boom number today all right you got it
that's your gun oh I can already hear
what kind of cereal this is what do you
think it is vivid cocoa wish me Cocoa
Krispies mm-hmm hmm
definitely a chocolaty kind using its up
cocoa pebbles it kind of has like that
bubbly fixture I think it took all of
Vicki you're going up over Christmas and
I want to take little pebbles okay
thank you love these there's no love of
it you're not worried about getting too
full and while you're digging in ready
for the fourth one your hook all right
let's do it I'm gonna I wanna kinda has
a little more going on my hand it's a
little funny
aids is here you munching away you're
good
[Music]
flats through West Adela
go for it owner what share experiences
we think let me I don't know I haven't
tried again I'm waiting for you let me
know what you think
oh really
another easy one it's like it's like now
it's possibly so the rustling you
thought I was falsely excited like this
was for sure across the face yeah
disgusting
oh man mmm-hmm
you're right this is definitely a
process like you know I was younger
uh-huh about your age huh I used to love
eating causes like I would cut up a
banana put it in there and then I was
get born full of sugar and add more
sugar that syrup and believe it I was I
have such a sweet peas in a little I'll
say I could do that now as a grownup too
sugary huh so we're going across the
slice then right here
awesome next one alright number
haha no middle what how do you say five
in Spanish
pink pink cool yeah it does tinkle
alright you ready to try this
I like creating it put it off for look
just not very free and okay hmm maybe I
was just over you okay yeah uh-huh
I'm excited hmm no I think your eyes you
know might be fruitless
or maybe Apple Jacks oh no they're both
he's pretty similar what do you think
that's our second bite of my old Apple
Jacks
that's gonna be monster Applejack you
ready for the next one hmm awesome oh
[Music]
hey number six there you go well first
of all completely song it's called
feminine the memory come in in a in a
minute
Thin Man men kind of fun playing it
wrong ha good my man will it be played
mean yeah that was early early has
students in it I could take that little
rodent I'd ever done please ma'am oh man
I think you're right let's keep away
more like up with Jackson yell and I
should have known could you know growing
up Applejack for a while it was my
favorite cereal but now I'm a grown up
I've had so many favorite cereals drop
my life I really can't this one anymore
but Applejack I explained all the timing
you're right it tastes just like
Applejack comes with a protective is
that our answer yes Applejack
cool next one
all right number and we help Marita what
do you think
where's the child like but does it taste
like it sounds like we're just going oh
my god what is it what is liate out what
is it therefore in Cocoa Krispies the
other one little bubble yep really yeah
why want me to say that I tried to
chocolate boy it's ill yeah what are you
saying this is a pickle Christy this one
cuz I can taste it
and then I painted it for ya the other
one was on your right you got a point
god I think arisings is not just way
more like Cocoa Krispies because there's
a snap crackle and pop right and I'm all
right so Cocoa Krispies you see next one
and at all what all number eight baby
was just not like you time support what
is the favorite series truly people's
broody people's this was that one people
everything foodie trouble Brady pelo MLA
no screaming Mallory Aidid are you for
sure yep all right okay mmm great Baba
for sure I'm normal one count
I got a few pebbles at four fruity
pebbles and then your milk mm-hmm and I
poured a little more sugar really
exactly the same really
oh man you have a kid tastebuds you
can't taste things are way too sweet how
you love eating the frosting on cakes
too huh mm-hmm
yeah I don't know you're gonna lose it
when you get older though buddy no sorry
I thought that was your shoulders are
you ready for the next one we're saying
for disables right
all right next one please
[Music]
know where they do benign with a sound
like little crunchy what do you say
they're serious before what is it
please read this book ah you think that
was my favorite three older ones
it should be because I do love Reese's
peanut butter cups would a big Reese's
puffs man hmm
yeah there's no denying that Reese's
flavor at all if it wasn't but in a
better flavor of probably is like cocoa
puffs or something yeah there's nothing
real curse not just regular milk okay
next one oh yeah
number ten whoo all right you're digging
in right away here already oh okay what
I to me I got my slippers in the wrong
way
Oh lifted overall naturally the whole
bag how funny he may be able to grab
some milk or China what do you think let
me try to do you think what do you think
cuz you're nice I have to poop oh you
know just brings up already memory drive
in it go huh yep
this is cocoa puffs I see these all the
time
oh you know bekommen in here Oh Michael
so old but it was a cocoa puffs they had
this cereal box but if you cut certain
parts so you can like create like a
certain type of like tube to put your
clothes through the box and it was like
a slide so much fun but now there's a
really she goes through a lots of time
you the reasons that go through a lot of
yeah I guess I could whenever I eat
breakfast I would get bored I just sleep
it through the book but before they
still let you out please do cool things
with a box I remember like a couple
weeks ago
oh but I don't know Halloween so like
wait for hmm in the block it has like a
type of character like vampire
sir I'll wear all see so then you can
cut it out and glue some guard oh is it
like a mask yeah oh cool but I guess the
exact so doing cool things with your
boxes all right so we're onto a cocoa
puffs yep go up up next one numero one
one only patch 111 school was it's not
like it's saying oh it's fruity leaving
it picks trick isn't oh I can eat this
you know why why cuz Trix are only for
kids
okay oh yeah such a mom joke hmm
there's no denying that doesn't strike
me as a super king you fruity flavor huh
you know they still have tricks shaped
as a fruit three but now I think these
days they only have them in circles on a
night of it yeah having to cook yeah I
wonder why they can't see it I really
like seeing like different fruit shake
do you never saw it that way you know oh
man I got to show you some photos
I got to Google it Google Translate is
good 10
all right next one
all right your metal last one yeah last
one I'm looking forward to seeing
oh me too I feel my eyes off switch yeah
okay you ready to begin your please test
my hot hot hot hot hot I love tops too I
had a very obvious
I had a phase of pop - no doubt mmm mmm
mmm
so your honor all right I have it okay
one good if I'm ready 1 2 3
oh we're missing it ha ha ha laughs what
what ah point is please oh you almost
got my baby specialist does a good nice
high-five all right let's have case you
take this one away the final one and
then we're going to find out how many
without right a mom all right
oh that's not right that's a ascator
right all right all right we can't
ignore it okay yeah let's see how many
we got right number one
look you guys yes senator and dating
dating day did you get her there was no
indicate we're gonna get there only do
we eat cinnamon toast times like every
single morning here all right number two
both yes Lucky Charms elect oh yeah I'm
going all right these custom ones number
three I think again it was not Cocoa
Krispies
I hope whirring my god no you get cocoa
pebbles yep
[Music]
it's okay I think that Chris needed
after hop yes all right number four both
yes chef
roughly fans ah ah
all right here level five idea truth
mm-hmm yes okay I did I did yeah it was
fruitless
oh yeah and yeah all right number six
number six you've both done the rest
okay all that's my cleanser panting
sorry and I realize though that would
like being happen all right
number seven both cover is love combo
crispy crispy all right number eight
there's no way how we're gonna get this
on Isaac what's your favorite cereal
literally table for the dirty memos all
right number nine Reese's Bob both got a
friend look haha it couldn't be any
other peanut butter cereal that I know
that's popular casting peanut butter oh
yeah you're right
all right number ten cocoa puffs yeah
[Music]
number 11 right okay whoa we're both you
guys what we both kind of riding another
freaking is the wrong with letting this
is along that the wall with a wrong bag
all Bob that's right we write it you got
to teach me now I feel like I'm out of
touch with kids having via fun arms in
oh yeah Big Damn huh so like this no
that's the wrong way this way right oh
yeah armpit counties
the next and last one
Oh ding-ding-ding-ding we got a rough
night I have a dog hi thank you for
watching our voice full-rigged cereal
challenge it was pretty cool cuz we
actually knew most of the cereal huh
yeah we actually tested our knowledge
and we pretty much succeeded right yep
so make sure to leave a comment down
below there any other challenges that
you guys would like to see us do and
make sure to leave a big thumbs up and
we will see you guys next time
oh yeah yeah [ __ ]
[Music]